tu as dans les stations du littoral à la
saison touristique commence de plus en
plus tôt depuis quelques années dès les
vacances de février les français aiment
profiter du grand air marin en gironde
par exemple les plus téméraires se lance
même dans l'ascension de la dune du
pilat reportage david badié sébastien en
place dans son genre c'est le plus haut
sommet d'europe
mais même pendant les vacances d'hiver
les touristes qui entreprennent son
ascension n'aime pas forcément la neige
cette petite montagne on à la montagne à
la mer ce qui est agréable
du haut de la dune du pilat l'océan en
récompense le site depuis quelques
années attirent les vacanciers de
février que ceux des stations de ski ne
se moque pas c'est une vraie ascension
et s'en tire fesses
la être à peu près tranquille on vient
de la région parisienne est typiquement
on essaie de trouver un peu moins de
monde à plus de calme ça vaut le coup
d'oeil et on est impressionné par cette
étendue et liberté très très très jolie
nature tranquillité le littoral aquitain
séduit depuis deux ans une nouvelle
clientèle soucieuse de sortir des
sentiers battus des vacances d'hiver car
l'hiver on peut aussi avoir les pieds en
éventail sur la plage à la montagne il y
avait une attente comme on dit si on
avait eu un espace de liberté on peut
rouler sans trop rester dehors quand tu
mets ton char à voile promenade en
bateau thalassothérapie deltaplane ces
activités restent désormais ouverte en
hiver on en a connu mon palier les
terres mais aussi beaucoup de monde donc
on s'est dit et l'hiver il ya moins de
monde sur la plage ça doit être super
avec en plus le soleil au zénith et sa
parole de bikini en juillet ce n'est pas
garant